almost like a crazy of Angelica I've
always known that the age of design is
upon us almost like a rapture
you know if the day is sunny I think oh
the gods have had a good design day you
know or I go to a show and I see a
beautiful piece by an artist
particularly beautiful he's so good
because he clearly looked to design to
understand what he needed to do so I
really do believe that design is the
highest form of creative expression
that's why I'm talking to you today
about the age of design and the age of
design is the age in which design is
still cute furniture is still posters is
still fast cars what you see at MoMA
today but in truth what I really would
like to explain to the public and to the
audience's of MoMA is that the most
interesting chairs are the ones that are
actually made by a robot like this
beautiful chair by dirk van der koi
where a robot deposits a toothpaste like
slur of recycled refrigerators parts as
if he were a little big candy and makes
a chair out of it or good design our
digital fonts that we use all the time
and that become part of our identity i
want people to understand that design is
so much more than cute chairs that it is
first and foremost everything that is
around us in our life and it's
interesting how so much of what we're
talking about tonight is not simply
designed but interaction design and in
fact interaction design is what I've
been trying to insert in the collection
of the Museum of Modern Art for a few
years starting not very timidly but just
you know pointedly with works for
instance by Martin Wattenberg the way a
machine plays chess with itself that you
see here or Lisa Strauss told and her
partner's the sugar interface for the
One Laptop Per child
Toshio a wise tenori-on musical
instruments you know and Philip
Worthington shadow monsters and John
Maeda as reactive books and also you
know Jonathan Harrison said can bars I
want you to want me these were some of
the first acquisitions that really
introduced the
of interaction designed to the public
but more recently I've been trying
really to go even deeper into
interaction design with examples that
are emotional really suggestive and the
really explained interaction design at a
level that is almost undeniable the wind
map by wattenberg and Fernanda Viegas
sudden if you've ever seen it it's
really fantastic it looks at the
territory of the United States as if it
were a wheat field that is right like
record by the winds and that is really
giving you a pictorial image of what's
going on with the winds in the United
States but also more recently we started
acquiring videogames and that's where
all hell broke loose in a really
interesting way there are still people
that believe that there's a high and
there's a low and that's really what I
find so intriguing about the reactions
that we've had to the anointment of
videogames in the MoMA collection we've
you know first of all New York Magazine
always gets it I love them so we are in
the right quadrant we are in the
highbrow that's daring that's courageous
and brilliant which is great
timidly you know we've been higher in
the diagonal in other situations but
it's okay it's good it's good it's good
but here comes the art critic oh that
was fantastic so the first was Jonathan
Jones from The Guardian sorry MoMA video
games are not art did I ever say there
were arts I was talking about
interaction design excuse me exhibiting
pac-man and Tetris alongside Picasso and
Van Gogh they're two floors away
will mean came over for any real
understanding of art I'm bringing in the
end of the world you know we were
talking about the rapture it's coming
and Jonathan Jones is making it happen
so the same Guardian rebuts our video
games art the debate that shouldn't be
last week garden art critic blah blah
suggested the games cannot qualify as
art but if he write and does it matter
thank you does it matter you know it's
like once again there's this whole
problem of design being often
misunderstood for art or the idea that
is so diffused that designers want to
aspire to would like to be called
artists no designers aspire to be really
great designers thank you very much and
that's more than enough so my knight in
shining armor John Maeda without any
prompt came out with this big
declaration on wired videogames belong
in the MoMA and that was fantastic and I
thought that was it but then there was
another wonderfully pretentious article
that came out in The New Republic so
pretentious by Lee libelous and he said
MoMA has mistaken videogames for art
again the museum is putting pacman
alongside Picasso again that misses the
point excuse me you're missing the point
and here look the above question is put
bluntly are videogames art no video
games aren't art because they are quite
thoroughly something else code so
because it's not art because it's oil
paint you're right so it's so fantastic
to see how these feathers that were
ruffled and this reactions were so
vehement and you know what the
international cat video film festival
didn't have that much of a reaction I
think this was truly fantastic we were
talking about dancing ponies but I was
really jealous of the Walker Art Center
for putting up this festival because
it's very very wonderful and you know
there's this flow backwards that I love
I have always tried to live in an ivory
tower but a tide of [ __ ] is beating at
its walls threatening to undermine it I
consider myself the tide of [ __ ]
we have to go through that you know even
in the nineteen thirties my colleagues
that we're trying to put together an
abstract art show had all of these works
stopped by the customs officers that
decided they were not art so it's
happened before and it will happen in
the future but right now I can tell you
that I am so so proud to be able to call
pac-man part of the MoMA collection and
the same with for instance Tetris
original version of the Soviet one and
you know the amount of work yeah Alexey
Pajitnov was was working for the Soviet
government and that's how he developed
Tetris and Alex EA himself reconstructed
the whole game and even gave us a
simulation of the cathodic ray tube that
makes it look slightly you know like
it'll slightly bumped and it's fantastic
so behind these acquisitions is an
enormous amount of work because we're
still the museum of modern art so even
when we tackle popular culture we tackle
it as a form of interaction design is
something that has to go into the
collection of moment therefore has to be
researched so to get to choosing Eric's
is wonderful another world amongst
others we put together a panel of
experts and we worked on this
acquisition and it's mostly myself and
Kate Carmody and Paul Galloway we worked
on it for a year and a half so many
people helped us designers of games you
might know jae-min Warren and his
collaborators that kill screen magazine
and you know Kevin Slavin you name it we
bugged everybody because we knew that we
were ignorant we were not real gamers
enough so we had to really talk to them
and so we decided of course to have
SimCity 2000 not the other SimCity that
one in particular so the criteria that
we developed along the way were really
strong and will not only criteria of
selection there were also criteria of
exhibition and of preservation that's
what makes this acquisition more than a
little game or a little joke it's truly
a way to think of how to preserve and
show artefact that will more and more
become part of our lives in the future
we live today as you know very well not
in the digital not in the physical but
in the
kind of minestrone that our mind makes
of the two and that's really where
interaction lies and that's the
importance of interaction and in order
to explain interaction we need to really
bring people in and make them realize
how interaction is part of their lives
so when I talk about it I don't talk
only about video games which are in a
way the purest form of interaction are
not alter aided by any kind of
functional finality I also talked about
the MetroCard vending machine which I
consider a masterpiece of interaction I
mean that interface is beautiful it
looks like a burly MTA guy coming out of
the tunnel you know you can with your
mitt you can actually park the MetroCard
and I talked about how bad ATM machine
you know usually are so I let people
understand that it's up to them to know
how to judge interactions so as to know
when it's good or when it's bad
so when I show the Sims I try to make
people really feel what it meant to have
an interaction with the sames not only
the fun but also the responsibility that
came with the Tamagotchi you know video
games can be truly deep even when
they're completely mindless I'm sure
that all of you know Katamari Damacy
it's about rolling a ball and picking up
as many objects as you can in a finite
amount of time and hopefully you'll be
able to make it into a planet I've never
made into a planet but that's it
or Nova Britain was not distributed here
in the United States it was a
PlayStation game but mostly for Japan
and it was one of the first video games
in which you could choose your own music
so you would put into the PS station you
would put your own CD and then the game
would change alongside your music so
really fantastic not to mention EVE
Online even line is an artificial
universe if you wish but one of the
diplomats that was killed in Benghazi
not ambassador Stevens but one of his
collaborators was a really big shot in
EVE Online so here you have a diplomat
in the real world that spends his time
in EVE Online to kind of test maybe all
of his ideas about diplomacy and about
universe building and to the point that
the first announcement of the bombing
was actually given on EVE Online and
after his death several parts of the
universe were named after him and I was
just recently at the evil mind
fan festival at written Reykjavik that
was quite amazing I mean we're talking
about an experience that of course can
seem weird to many but that is very
educational of course there are games
that are even more educational Dwarf
Fortress is like the holy grail of this
kind of massive multiplayer online games
and in fact the two Adams brothers were
in Reykjavik and they were like they
were greeted by standing ovations by all
the EVE Online fans it was like amazing
to see and it's a beautiful game
so you start seeing here that the
aesthetics that are so important to a
museum collection like moments are kept
alive also by the selection of these
games and you know valve you know portal
is an example of a video game in which
you have a certain type of violence
which also leads me to talk about one of
the biggest issues that we had to
discuss when we acquired the video games
what to do with violence right we had to
make decisions at MoMA interestingly
there's a lot of violence depicted in
the art part of the collection but when
I came to MoMA 19 years ago and as an
Italian I said you know what we need a
Beretta I was told like no no guns in
the design collection I was like why
interestingly I learned that it's
considered that in design and the design
collection what you see is what you get
so when you see a gun it's an instrument
for killing in the design collection if
it's in the art collection it might be a
critique of the killing instruments so
it's very interesting but we are
acquiring our critical dimensionals and
design so maybe one day we'll be able to
acquire also the guns but here in this
particular case we decided we know with
Kate and Paul that we would have no
gratuitous violence so we have portal
because you shoot walls in order to
create new spaces we have Street Fighter
to cause martial arts are good but we
don't have
but we don't have GTA because maybe it's
my own reflection I've never been able
to do anything but crashing cars and
shooting prostitutes and pimps you know
so it was not very constructive but you
know valve so that so a lot I'm making
fun of it but we discussed this for so
many days I mean I can you have no idea
and to this day I am ambivalent but when
you have instead games like flow there's
no doubt it's like it's about serenity
and it's about sublime it's about
experiencing what it means to be a sea
creature now we have a few of the side
scrollers classical once so it's quite a
hefty collection and right now we
started with the first 14 but we have
several that are coming up and the
reason why we haven't acquired them yet
is because we don't acquire just the
game you acquire the relationship with
the company what we want what we aspire
to is the code it's very hard to get of
course but that's what would enable us
to preserve the video games for a really
long time and that's what museums do
they also preserve artifacts for
posterity in absence of the code because
you know video game company companies
are not that very forthcoming in some
cases in absence of that we we acquire
the relationship with the company we're
gonna stay with them forever they're not
gonna get rid of us and one day we'll
get that code so it but I want to I want
to explain to you the the criteria that
we chose for interaction design
aesthetics are really important and I'm
showing you core war here which is an
early game that takes advantage
aesthetically of the limitations of the
processor so the kind of interferences
that you see here that look like
beautiful barriers in the game are
actually a consequence of the processors
limitedness which is fantastic so
aesthetics is always important and so is
space the spatial aspect of games you
know I feel that the best video games
are the ones that have really savvy
architects that are behind them and if
they're not architects bonafide trained
as architecture they have that feeling
but the spatial evolution in video games
is extremely important time the way we
experience time in video games as in
other forms of interaction design is
really quite amazing it can be real-time
or it can be the time within the game
as is in animal crossing where seasons
follow each other at their own pace so
time-space aesthetics and then most
important behavior the real core issue
of interaction design is behavior
designers that deal with interaction
design behaviors that go to influence
the rest of our lives they're not just
limited to our interaction with the
screen in this case I'm showing you
marble madness which is a beautiful game
which the the controller is a big sphere
that vibrates with you so you have a
sphere that's moving in this landscape
and the sphere the controller itself
gives you a sense of the movement in a
way you can see how video games are the
purest aspect of interaction designer
are very useful to explain what
interaction is we don't want to show the
video games with the paraphernalia no
arcade nostalgia if anything we want to
show the code and here you see Ben fries
distill a map of pac-man or the pac-man
code so the way we acquired the games is
very interesting and very unorthodox you
see them here displayed alongside other
example of design you know furniture and
other parts but there's no paraphernalia
no nostalgia only the screen and a
little shelf or the controllers the
controllers are of course part of the
experience so you cannot deal do away
with it but interestingly this choice
was not condemned to vehemently by
gamers I was afraid that they would kill
us and instead they understood
especially when I told them that I was
trying to apply the same strategy on
that phillyd onsen applied in 1934 when
he wanted to make people understand the
importance of design and he took
propeller blades and pieces of machinery
and in the MoMA galleries he put them on
white pedestals against white walls as
if they were Brancusi sculptures he
created the strange distance this shock
that made people realize how gorgeous
formally and also important functionally
design pieces were I would like to do
the same with videogames by getting rid
of the sticky carpets and the cigarette
butts and everything else that we might
remember from our childhood I want
people to understand I want people to
understand that those are important
forms of design
and in a way the videogames the fonts
and everything else lead us to to make
people understand a wider meaning for
design one of my dream acquisitions
which has been on hold for a few years
but now will come back on the front
burner is a 747
I would like to acquire it but without
owning it I don't want it to be at
moment possessed by moment I wanted to
keep flying
so it's an acquisition where MoMA makes
an arrangement with an airline and keeps
the Boeing the 747 fly and the same with
the add sign that we acquired a few
years ago it was the first example of an
acquisition of something that is in the
public domain and what I say to people
it's almost as if a butterfly were
flying by and we captured the shadow on
the wall and just we're showing the
shadow so in a way we're showing a
manifestation of something that is truly
important and that is part of our
identity but that nobody can have and
it's too long to explain the acquisition
but if you want to go on the MoMA blog
there's a long post where I explain why
it's such a great example of design
along the way I've had to burn a few
chairs you know I have had to do away
with a few concepts of design past but I
see that people are coming along that
the audience is paradoxically are much
more responsive and much more
understanding of this expansion of
design than some of my colleagues are
design is truly everywhere and design is
as important as anything and I'm so glad
that because of its diversity and
because of its centrality to our life
many more people are coming to it as a
profession as a passion and that's very
simply part of their own culture thank
you very much
[Music]
you